-Bonjour à tous.
Comment en finir avec le béton
qui grignote nos paysages,
quand les Français se rêvent tous
propriétaires
d'une maison individuelle
et que l'Etat fait face
à une crise du logement,
quand la France
est championne d'Europe
des grandes surfaces
et pas la dernière
en ce qui concerne
l'artificialisation des sols ?
-Dans les années 70, Daphné,
un Français, en moyenne,
vivait dans 25 mètres carrés.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est 40 mètres carrés
de surface habitable par personne.
Conséquence : des constructions
et des sols plus artificialisés.
L'étalement urbain augmente
trois fois plus vite
que la population.
Chaque année,
l'équivalent
de la surface de Marseille
disparaît sous une route,
un supermarché, un parking
ou une zone pavillonnaire.
Un paradoxe, pour finir :
la part grandissante
de logements vacants, vides,
cohabite avec le manque persistant
de logements.
-Sur le terrain,
les élus se lamentent
de la désertification
des centres-villes,
mais se crispent
face à la sobriété foncière.
Il va falloir lever le pied
pour protéger nos écosystèmes,
lutter contre l'étalement urbain
et les inondations.
Les sols stockent du carbone
et retiennent l'eau.
Ils agissent donc sur
et pour le climat.
L'Etat vise le ZAN en 2050,
non pas la célèbre friandise
à la réglisse,
mais la zéro
artificialisation nette.
Comment faire pour que
ça ne reste pas un voeu pieux ?
C'est la question.
Au fait, maman, j'ai arrêté l'avion.
Générique
...
Comment concilier
urgence écologique,
crise du logement,
vitalité économique
et épuisement des ressources ?
Hélène Peskine, vous êtes architecte
urbaniste en chef de l'Etat
et secrétaire générale du PUCA,
le Plan
Urbanisme Construction Architecture.
A vos côtés, Philippe Bihouix,
ingénieur,
directeur général de l'AREP,
plus grande agence
de maîtrise d'oeuvre
en France
et laboratoire
de l'écoconception,
et auteur notamment
de "La ville stationnaire".
Sylvain Massonneau,
vous siégez
à la Fédération française
du bâtiment
et êtes directeur de Tradimaisons,
votre entreprise de construction.
Bonjour et bienvenue
à vous trois.
Avant toute chose,
intéressons-nous
à l'habitat.
La maison individuelle,
ce rêve que la France promeut
depuis les années 60
serait-il un modèle
à déconstruire ?
Le BTP représente 25 %
des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
Il y a urgence
à changer de logiciel,
mais le rythme des constructions
ne baisse pas.
Seule la grogne monte.
Le Tout oppose,
c'est un reportage d'Emma Guizot
et Xavier Luizet.
Jingle
...
Musique douce
-Angers,
la ville où il fait
le plus bon vivre en France,
d'après de nombreux palmarès.
Il s'agit d'une ville verte
aux espaces naturels nombreux.
Dans le quartier
des Hauts-de-Saint-Aubin,
une prairie de 6000 mètres carrés
donne aux riverains
comme Karine
un sentiment de campagne.
-Je vais vous montrer
la beauté de ce parc
en plein coeur d'Angers.
Regardez ça.
Et voilà.
Le matin,
j'ai du silence.
On entend au loin les voitures.
On est quand même
dans une ville,
mais on entend en même temps
les oiseaux tout le temps.
On respire.
Musique intrigante
-Mais ce parc-là
est menacé.
Un projet de lotissement
doit bientôt y voir le jour.
19 logements,
dont 10 maisons individuelles.
Une zone de plus
promise à la bétonnisation.
-Quand je suis venue ici,
ce qui m'a fait craquer,
c'est le parc,
où mes enfants pouvaient aller
après et avant l'école,
le week-end...
J'invitais des amis en bas
à jouer à la pétanque
ou je jouais au basket
avec mon fils. Clairement,
je ne pourrai pas supporter
de voir les arbres tomber.
-Début octobre,
le permis de construire
a été accordé par la mairie.
Karine et d'autres riverains
ont fondé un collectif.
Ce soir, alors que
le conseil municipal
se réunit,
ils ont décidé de se mobiliser
devant la mairie...
-Vous êtes angevin ?
-...pour informer les citoyens.
-On se mobilise.
Dans un des quartiers
des Hauts-de-Saint-Aubin,
on va nous retirer
un îlot de fraîcheur
pour construire des maisons.
Je sais pas à quelle heure
ils vont venir, les élus.
-On veut pas de béton.
On veut pas que
les arbres soient coupés.
On veut que les enfants
de l'école primaire découvrent
ce que c'est que la faune,
la flore.
-Il y a souvent
un grand discours
théorique sur l'écologie,
comment préserver notre planète,
mais rien que dans nos quartiers,
il se passe des trucs de dingue.
-Les riverains interpellent
une élue
qui a voté pour ce projet :
Sophie Foucher-Maillard,
pourtant membre de la liste
Angers Ecologique et Solidaire.
-Il n'y avait pas la même météo
et le même climat
il y a 30 ans que maintenant.
Conserver des arbres
en temps de canicule,
ça me semble prioritaire.
-On a un maire qui est resté
dans le 20e siècle,
je crois.
-Il faut
un petit peu de nuance.
Il y a des gens en manque
de logement. Où les met-on ?
Musique rythmée
-Alors, faut-il bétonner ou pas ?
Comment construire
de nouveaux logements
sans polluer ?
La France artificialise
chaque année
20 à 30 000 ha de terrain,
soit deux à trois fois
la ville de Paris.
Le premier facteur est
la construction
de logements.
68 % des sols
artificialisés
le sont pour cela,
accélérant le changement climatique,
nuisant à la biodiversité
et perturbant le cycle de l'eau,
mais le BTP emploie
près de deux millions de personnes
et les Français rêvent
de maison individuelle.
Les besoins en logement augmentent.
Peut-on continuer
de construire ?
Le modèle
du pavillon
est-il soutenable ?
Deux visions s'opposent.
Yannick Neuder est
député de l'Isère,
vice-président
de la région Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes.
Héloïse Leussier,
journaliste à Reporterre,
média écologiste.
-Il y a de gros besoins,
effectivement,
de construire des logements.
Il faut accepter que
tout le monde n'a pas forcément
envie de vivre dans une tour,
dans une métropole.
-Le pavillon avec jardin
pour tous ceux qui en voudraient,
c'est sûr que c'est impossible.
Les industriels qui tendent
à continuer à vendre ce rêve,
eh bien, sont en train
de tromper les gens.
Musique vive
-La Ville-du-Bois,
dans l'Essonne, près de Paris.
Un petit village propret
de 17 maisons,
toutes neuves,
coquettes et vides,
car, en réalité,
personne n'habite ici.
Nous sommes à Domexpo,
un catalogue à ciel ouvert,
le village
des maisons à essayer.
C'est ici que
les Français viennent
toucher du doigt leur rêve,
comme Miora et Christian.
Ils ont deux jeunes enfants
et ras-le-bol de vivre
dans un appartement.
-Je vais vous présenter
un petit peu le pavillon.
Là, on a une cuisine ouverte
avec un îlot central.
Tout l'espace ici
fait 72 mètres carrés.
Je vais vous montrer
les chambres en haut
et on ira dans mon bureau.
-Ici, ils vont choisir
le modèle de la maison
qu'ils vont faire construire.
-Installez-vous.
C'est vrai que,
à la sortie du Covid,
il y a eu un engouement
pour les pavillons.
Le fait d'être confiné
dans un appartement
a donné envie à beaucoup de monde
d'avoir un petit jardin
pour pouvoir faire des barbeucs.
-Miora et Christian sont conquis
et prêts à signer.
-297 000 euros
pour avoir un F3,
un petit bureau
et un petit jardin
de 100 mètres carrés.
-J'espère réaliser
leur ambition.
Maintenant, on va visiter
le terrain à Saint-Chéron.
A l'issue de cette visite,
madame va valider,
si l'environnement est OK
à 200 %.
-Un pavillon
individuel,
c'est plus qu'un simple habitat.
C'est un lieu à soi,
un idéal
directement importé
des Etats-Unis,
né après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
dans l'esprit de cet homme,
William Levitt,
roi des banlieues,
serial promoteur des pavillons.
Il met en place
ces zones résidentielles
immenses.
-Partout dans le pays,
38 000 maisons ont été
construites en 1958.
Produites en masse,
elles ne coûtent
que 10 000 dollars chacune.
Ces jeunes familles
profitent d'un morceau
du rêve américain.
Ces dizaines de milliers
de pavillons signent
l'avènement
des classes moyennes américaines.
-C'est la belle vie
en banlieue.
-Un modèle qui modifie
pour toujours les paysages.
La maison individuelle
s'étale toujours plus loin
des centres-villes.
C'est le règne du tout-voiture,
avec routes, échangeurs
et ronds-points.
Ce modèle arrive en France
à la fin des années 60,
soutenu par les pouvoirs publics.
Le pays doit devenir
une nation de propriétaires.
-C'est près
de 90 % des Français
qui ont envie
d'être propriétaires
de leur logement.
C'est parce que vous imaginez
que la qualité de vie
est différente,
est meilleure,
avec un peu le rêve
du pavillon,
de la maison,
des enfants, du chien.
-La fast fashion consomme
du vêtement.
Là, on va consommer du logement.
On va construire, construire,
faire croire à ce rêve
que la maison est accessible à tous,
ce qui est impossible
en termes d'espace.
Ca nécessiterait de détruire
trop d'espaces naturels.
Musique dramatique
Or, en France,
10 % du territoire est déjà bétonné,
contre moins de 3 %
au niveau européen.
Ce n'est pas près de s'arrêter.
A Sens-de-Bretagne,
un projet de lotissement
menace un petit bois
aux arbres centenaires.
-Oh, j'ai trouvé des racines !
-L'artificialisation des sols
détruit la biodiversité,
car bétonner,
c'est recouvrir la terre,
l'imperméabiliser
et porter atteinte à ses fonctions
biologiques.
-Alors, le cèdre de l'Atlas...
-Ce jour-là,
le collectif Araucaria a décidé
de montrer au grand public
tous les arbres qui vont
être détruits.
-Tiens. Vas-y. Fais le tour.
-Le but de ces petits panneaux,
c'est de sensibiliser
et de révéler
ce que contient ce parc,
parce que, en fait, on peut pas dire
que c'est que des sapins.
Quand on a eu les premiers échanges
avec le lotisseur, il a dit :
"Oui, il va falloir couper,
mais c'est que des sapins."
Il y a autre chose
que des sapins.
Il y a une quarantaine d'arbres,
plein d'arbustes,
donc c'est dommage, en fait,
de supprimer tout ça.
-Les arbres et les sols
stockent le CO2.
Tous ont leur utilité
et alimentent des écosystèmes vitaux
pour la biodiversité
en plein effondrement.
-Les ronces ont poussé.
Au travers des ronces
poussent les jeunes arbres,
les jeunes qui se sont resemés.
Vous voyez surgir des noyers.
Vous voyez surgir des petits chênes,
des petits châtaigniers, etc.
Les ronces les protègent
des prédateurs,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
assez de force
pour commencer à pousser
et à devenir grands.
Toutes les espèces
qui sont ici,
même celles qu'on n'aime pas,
c'est-à-dire même les ronces,
les orties,
ont un rôle à jouer
dans la biodiversité.
Toutes.
Toutes sans exception.
-Le terrain est privé.
Les travaux pourraient commencer
à n'importe quel moment,
mais le collectif compte
lancer des recours.
Au niveau national,
une loi a été votée
en juillet dernier
pour essayer d'enrayer
cette bétonnisation
galopante.
C'est le ZAN,
pour "zéro artificialisation nette"
des terres naturelles et agricoles,
un objectif imposé par la loi
climat et résilience de 2021.
Durant 10 ans,
les élus doivent diviser par deux
le rythme d'artificialisation
des terres.
Puis, à partir de 2050,
il ne leur sera plus possible
de consommer
le moindre hectare de terre
sans en rendre l'équivalent
à la nature.
C'est l'idée
de compensation écologique.
-Quand vous devez
aménager un espace,
vous pouvez enlever des arbres,
si vous en replantez le double.
On peut effectivement
construire à un endroit
qui n'était pas construit,
donc l'artificialiser,
si, par ailleurs,
dans un autre endroit,
on revégétalise
ou, de nouveau, on rend
perméables ces surfaces.
-Cette idée
qu'on pourrait détruire,
puis reconstruire par ailleurs
l'équivalent, en termes
de qualité écologique,
c'est faux.
Si vous détruisez une forêt
où il y a des arbres
depuis des décennies,
toute une vie
qui s'est installée,
vous n'allez jamais retrouver
la même qualité écologique.
Cela prend vraiment
beaucoup de temps
pour que la vie revienne
à nouveau.
-Pour beaucoup de communes,
une seule solution :
redensifier les centres-villes
pour éviter l'étalement urbain.
-Je vais fermer.
-Y a pas d'ouvriers.
-Nous retournons à Angers,
où la destruction d'un parc
est contestée par les riverains.
Selon son promoteur
et son architecte,
le projet est vertueux.
-Voilà. Donc...
On est sensiblement par ici.
En fait, derrière vous,
quatre maisons vont s'étaler
sur toute la longueur.
-Il s'agit de densifier
des parcelles vacantes
en ville
ou dans les villages,
des "dents creuses",
selon les urbanistes.
Une solution qui permet
d'éviter la consommation
de zones rurales ou agricoles.
-Tout le monde veut bien
qu'on densifie la ville,
mais pas à côté de chez soi.
C'est un peu la règle.
On est très régulièrement soumis
à ce type de problème.
-Dans le principe du ZAN,
l'idée,
c'est quand même de construire
la ville sur la ville,
plutôt que d'étendre
en dehors de la collectivité,
ce qui génère des surcoûts,
des transports.
Ca va dans le sens de l'histoire
de construire dans la ville.
-Construire en ville
et sacrifier les îlots de verdure
ou bétonner à la campagne ?
Le dilemme est de taille.
L'été dernier,
Laurent Wauquiez,
président de la région
Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes,
a relancé le débat
en disant vouloir sortir du ZAN,
qu'il qualifie de "ruralicide",
destructeur pour les campagnes.
-Si on veut que les commerces
de proximité perdurent,
si on veut que les classes scolaires
puissent se maintenir,
il faut que
certaines communes puissent
avoir un certain nombre
de logements
pour le renouvellement
des populations.
Sinon, on va avoir
des territoires vieillissants,
sans aucun apport
de population nouvelle,
avec une économie au point mort
et plus aucun service.
-Mais bétonner
signifie-t-il vraiment
développer les zones rurales ?
En Loire-Atlantique,
ce n'est pas l'avis
de nombreux riverains
de la carrière du Tahun.
Depuis 35 ans,
cette carrière de grès
est inexploitée.
La nature
a repris ses droits,
les arbres ont repoussé
et la carrière
s'est remplie d'eau,
mais la préfecture a autorisé
un grand groupe de BTP
à reprendre l'activité.
Pendant 15 ans,
plus de deux millions de tonnes
de granulat seront extraites
et des déchets inertes du bâtiment
seront enfouis dans la carrière.
Musique grave
Ce jour-là,
des associations
et des riverains
sont réunis pour manifester
leur mécontentement.
Le moteur vrombit.
-Nous,
nos gamins ont appris
à nager ici,
pour certains.
Voilà. C'est un lieu
qui nous est cher.
On n'a pas envie de voir
80 camions tous les jours,
circuler dans les villages,
pour ensuite venir enfouir
des déchets du bâtiment.
Bah non !
Ni ici, ni ailleurs,
en fait.
Percussions
-Les projets de construction
concernent les villes de Nantes
et Rennes, à 50 km de là.
-Ils viennent
accaparer, en fait,
des ressources ici
et ils viennent, ensuite,
déposer des déchets.
On va recevoir les déchets
des villes.
La population se sent
elle-même aussi déchet,
mise au rebut de la même manière.
La foule chante.
...
-La construction
d'une maison individuelle
génère en moyenne
1,5 tonne de déchets
et prend 15 fois plus
d'espace au sol
que l'habitat collectif.
-On ne peut pas envisager,
en France,
des villages, demain,
où tout serait en collectif.
On ne pourra pas remplacer
un village de 300 habitants
par deux immeubles
de 20 étages.
-Ce qu'il faut,
c'est changer les imaginaires
et peut-être
qu'on peut rendre aussi
l'habitat en immeuble
plus enviable,
justement en gardant
des espaces verts,
en proposant des espaces
qui sont moins standardisés,
moins bétonnisés.
-Si le rythme d'artificialisation
ne ralentit pas,
280 000 hectares d'espaces naturels
supplémentaires
risquent d'être bétonnés
d'ici à 2030,
soit plus que la superficie
du Luxembourg.
-Alors, l'idéal de la maison
avec jardin est plébiscité
par 75 % des Français.
Face à l'urgence climatique,
ce rêve est-il,
comme l'affirmait
l'ancienne ministre
du Logement,
Emmanuelle Wargon,
un non-sens écologique ?
-D'abord,
le pavillon peut être un rêve
pour une jeune famille,
quand la famille s'agrandit,
que l'appartement est trop petit.
A un moment,
peut-être que ce rêve va
se transformer en difficulté.
Une fois les ados grands,
on passe son temps en voiture.
On en est dépendant.
Quand on vieillit, on n'a plus envie
de faire le jardin,
d'être loin du kiné,
du bar des copains
au moment de la retraite.
-Ca reste plébiscité,
quand même, largement.
-La question,
c'est de dire :
de quelle maison on parle
et quel rêve
on introduit
chez nos concitoyens ?
Il y a des envies
de métropole trépidante,
puis il y a d'autres temps de vie
et d'autres manières
d'habiter,
y compris dans une maison.
On peut imaginer
des choses comme du béguinage,
des gens qui vont décider
de vieillir ensemble,
de l'habitat intergénérationnel,
des couples âgés qui accueillent
un jeune actif, un étudiant.
-C'est marginal.
-Oui, mais ça pourrait
avoir vraiment un intérêt,
parce qu'on lutterait
contre ce puissant levier
qui est un levier
d'artificialisation
et un levier de demande
de logement en décohabitation.
On est passés
de 3,1 par foyer
dans les années 60
à 2,2-2,1, aujourd'hui.
Cela fait que, en effet,
même à population constante,
voire à population
légèrement décroissante,
comme en Allemagne,
il y a encore un puissant besoin
de construire
ou d'accueillir.
On doit aller chercher aussi,
et peut-être d'abord,
des mécanismes de sobriété
grâce à des mécanismes
de recohabitation.
C'est pas simple,
mais c'est à envisager.
-500 000 nouveaux logements par an
seraient nécessaires
pour éviter une crise
du logement majeure, en France.
Comment loger
davantage d'habitants
sans étendre toujours plus
les villes ?
-Pour revenir un petit peu
à la réponse précédente,
on a des maisons individuelles
sur le territoire.
30 % des Français habitent
dans une maison individuelle.
Elles existent.
On a toujours cette idée que,
la maison individuelle,
c'est des maisons en plus
à construire demain.
En réalité, on a la question
de qui habite
dans ces maisons,
et peut-être pas
les familles qui aspirent
légitimement à y accéder,
parce que
les gens ont effectivement
des aspirations à habiter
dans un logement plus grand,
avec un espace extérieur,
notamment au moment
de construire leur famille,
mais, d'abord,
les familles ne durent plus
30-40 ans, comme elles ont duré
ces dernières décennies.
De plus en plus, on a deux logements
pour une même famille,
avec des chambres en double.
-Peut-être que tout est déjà là.
La question est de valoriser
l'existant
ou de le transformer.
-Entre un tiers et deux tiers
sont déjà là,
mais ils ne sont pas
nécessairement là
où les gens veulent habiter.
-Concernant l'environnement,
le modèle le plus pertinent,
urbanistiquement parlant,
c'est quoi ?
Alors, on comprend que
c'est pas la maison individuelle.
Est-ce que c'est, pour autant,
la ville dense
et, comme on l'a entendu,
des bâtiments de 20 étages ?
Peut-on avoir
une direction architecturale
qui serait la moins impactante,
en termes environnementaux ?
-Ca fait un peu débat.
Il y a peu de recherche
en architecture sur le sujet.
Quelques articles
scientifiques
essaient de comparer
les émissions de CO2
sur un cycle de vie,
donc à la fois les matériaux...
Le CO2, l'énergie dans les matériaux
qu'on va utiliser,
et puis, ensuite,
sur la durée de vie
des quartiers ou des bâtiments.
Il semblerait qu'il y ait un seuil
de contre-productivité,
disait le fameux écrivain
Ivan Illich, dans les années 70.
Oui, le petit collectif
de quelques étages
serait plus efficace,
mais quand on passe
telle taille...
Est-ce que c'est 5, 10 étages ?
Là, on va mettre en oeuvre
des structures
beaucoup plus puissantes.
On va avoir des fondations
qui consomment
beaucoup de béton et d'acier.
Là, effectivement,
on passe
dans une gamme
où c'est bien moins intéressant
en consommation de ressources.
On est rattrapé
par la patrouille
et c'est moins bien.
C'est cette idée.
-La ville ultradense
n'est pas forcément
la solution.
-Quand on arrive dans des métropoles
où on se retrouve avec des projets
où on commence par construire
2 m d'épaisseur de béton
pour couvrir des voies ferroviaires,
puis mettre
des immeubles dessus
pour bien amortir le foncier,
là, il y a une intensité
en énergie
qui n'est peut-être pas
très rentable
sur la durée de vie,
mais l'aménagement du territoire,
c'est la vraie question.
On parle d'un stock.
Dès qu'on parle de la ville,
c'est un stock.
90 % de la ville de 2050
est déjà là.
C'est de ça qu'il faut s'occuper.
C'est pas juste du neuf
et de la transformation.
Un chiffre : si on veut suivre
la stratégie nationale bas carbone
telle qu'elle est
dans la loi aujourd'hui,
le programme de rénovation thermique
à mener
sur le logement,
l'équipement public, les bureaux,
il faut multiplier par 20
la vitesse à laquelle on va
aujourd'hui.
J'ignore comment on va faire ça,
avec quels moyens organisationnels,
humains, financiers,
mais c'est ça, l'idée.
Cette ville est déjà là :
30 millions
de résidences principales,
3,6 millions
de résidences secondaires
et de tourisme.
Pas que des longères normandes.
Il y a plein de petits appartements.
Et puis,
3 millions de logements vacants.
Sur ces logements vacants,
au moins un million sont vacants
depuis plus de deux ans.
Il y en a même
dans les zones tendues,
car ce sont des formes urbaines
qui plaisent moins :
on est en centre-ville,
on est moins éclairé,
on n'a pas la baie vitrée,
on n'a pas, potentiellement,
le jardin.
Aller chez le banquier
avec un projet de rénovation,
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'avec un projet neuf,
car il y a plus de risques,
plus de mauvaises surprises,
donc on n'a pas
forcément son prêt.
-Est-ce moins cher de construire
que de réhabiliter ?
-Aujourd'hui,
c'est une certitude.
Quand on échange
avec des promoteurs
privés
ou des bailleurs sociaux
sur la réhabilitation
du parc existant en ville,
ce qu'on constate,
c'est que le coût de fabrication
de remise à niveau
d'un logement ancien
en un logement
dans les standards neufs,
c'est le prix du neuf à + ou -20 %.
Là-dedans,
il y a quand même le coût
de l'acquisition du bâti initial.
On se retrouve donc
avec un prix de sortie
qui ne correspond pas
au prix du marché.
-Ca coûte
plus cher de rénover,
de réhabiliter.
-Le foncier urbain
coûte plus cher
que le foncier périurbain.
En fait,
l'équation part surtout
du niveau de prix
du foncier et du sol,
pas tellement du bâtiment,
qui est souvent une charge,
puisqu'il faut le réhabiliter
et le transformer.
La question, c'est plutôt :
à qui ça profite
et à qui ça ne profite pas ?
Les bénéfices de la réhabilitation
sont collectifs :
optimisation des réseaux
existants de la voirie,
des ordures ménagères,
des systèmes
d'infrastructure, d'énergie...
Ca profite
à la collectivité elle-même
qui aura moins de frais
de fonctionnement,
mais le développement du projet
d'un lotisseur en extension urbaine,
il profite à l'acheteur
et ça coûte à la collectivité,
car il faut étendre
les réseaux d'égouts, etc.
-Justement,
il y a peut-être un enjeu
des moyens mobilisés.
Il ne faudrait pas
lancer un plan Marshall
de la rénovation ?
-Il est un peu engagé,
on va dire ça comme ça,
en partie par cet objectif ZAN.
En fait,
cet objectif avait
pour vocation
de valoriser la biodiversité :
stop à l'artificialisation
pour sauver la biodiversité.
Ca nous indique
la valeur du sol.
Le sol est vivant. Il a des usages
très différents,
en ville comme en dehors,
qui peuvent être agricoles,
forestiers, vivriers,
mais aussi urbains
au sens social.
A partir du moment
où on donne
une valeur plus importante à ce sol,
car il devient plus rare,
on se pose une question :
vers quoi on veut l'orienter ?
Pour donner
un exemple contre-intuitif...
On travaille beaucoup
sur des petites et moyennes villes
où il y a des coeurs de bourg
qui sont un peu désertés.
Le premier levier
de réinvestissement
de ces coeurs de ville,
c'est la végétalisation,
donner du confort de vie,
dédensifier
des coeurs d'îlot
qui sont très anciens
ou qui ont été bâtis
en fond de cour,
pour redonner du sol vivant
en ville.
-Comment est-ce que
vous anticipez
la mise en place
progressive
du ZAN prévu par la loi ?
-La crise économique actuelle
est un bon exercice,
puisqu'on a -50 % de ventes
dans le logement neuf,
ce qui correspond
à l'objectif de 2030
fixé par l'Etat.
On va pouvoir tester,
économiquement et socialement,
le résultat
de la mise en application
du ZAN.
C'est un bon exercice.
Ca chahute un peu
les certitudes politiques.
-Ca chahute
le secteur du bâtiment.
La hausse du prix
des matières premières,
la frilosité des banques,
la hausse des taux d'intérêt...
-Il faut se diversifier.
On a évoqué la rénovation
qui est clairement
dans le viseur
de tous les acteurs
de la construction,
moi compris.
-Ca deviendrait
votre coeur de métier ?
-Coeur ou, en tout cas,
une activité certaine,
clairement identifiée,
mobilisable économiquement,
techniquement,
pour nos clients.
Ca,
on sait faire.
Ce qu'on ne sait pas bien faire,
c'est maîtriser le prix de sortie
pour qu'il soit accessible.
-Quels sont les leviers
sur le prix de sortie ?
-Plus on cherche,
plus on affine
les diagnostics en amont,
plus on peut maîtriser
les coûts de sortie.
On maîtrise les aléas.
C'est important de nous laisser
faire des expériences.
L'Etat devrait encourager
les expériences
- je suis désolé -
fiscalement.
Ca nécessite de l'argent.
-Une aide financière
pour orienter
vers la rénovation ?
-Ou des TVA plus claires.
Quand vous faites
de la rénovation lourde
de bâtiments,
entre la TVA à 10 et à 20,
c'est compliqué.
Résultat : redressement fiscal
et de la TVA à 20 partout.
Vous avez tout mangé.
Je crois que, là-dessus,
l'Etat se doit
d'accompagner le mouvement,
de se montrer peut-être généreux,
dans un premier temps,
pour pousser des acteurs
à se lancer là-dedans.
C'est indispensable.
L'autre gros levier
dont on a peu parlé
dans le reportage...
On a entendu "la bétonnisation".
Bien sûr qu'on utilise du béton,
mais c'est une matière première
extrêmement chère,
extrêmement émettrice de carbone,
donc on essaye
de la maîtriser au mieux.
En la maîtrisant au mieux,
on s'adosse
à des partenaires industriels
qui décarbonent tous lourdement,
soit dans la fabrication
du clinker,
des produits industriels finis :
planchers, prémurs, prédalles...
Ces industriels sortent
des produits qui, en deux ans,
ont perdu 30 % de poids carbone.
30 % !
On ne prend pas...
On ne prenait pas en compte
la carbonatation du béton
qui restocke dans son cycle de vie,
à peu près 15 % durant sa vie.
Au moment
où on va le déconstruire...
Ca a été dit avec la carrière.
Fragmenter le béton
augmente sa surface
et sa capacité à capter du béton.
-Du carbone.
-Pardon. Du carbone.
Le béton va restocker
entre 50 et 60 % du carbone
qu'il a émis pendant sa production.
C'est colossal.
-Vous vantez
les mérites du béton bas carbone.
Le béton vert,
mythe urbain ou réalité ?
-La prise en compte
de la carbonatation
pendant la durée de vie,
oui, on peut,
mais...
-Ca vous fait sourire.
-C'est pas une grande quantité,
par rapport à ce qui va être émis
nativement
dans une cimenterie,
quand on va fabriquer le clinker,
le composant principal,
avec quelques additifs,
du ciment.
Si le ciment venait,
dans quelques semaines,
à la COP28,
il serait troisième ex aequo
avec l'acier
au niveau mondial,
derrière la Chine
et les Etats-Unis.
On émet, malheureusement,
nativement du CO2.
Il n'y a pas
tellement de solution.
L'industrie nous propose
la capture
du CO2
et le stockage géologique.
D'ici à 2050, il va falloir
se retrousser les manches
pour qu'il y en ait suffisamment.
J'y crois à moitié.
-Deux tiers des logements
dans le monde
sont en béton,
responsable
d'au moins 5 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
On peut se demander
de quoi est fait le béton.
Raphaël Hitier,
ça tombe bien,
vous avez une réponse en béton.
C'est votre Climatoscope.
Jingle
...
-Dans le monde,
la plupart des constructions
se font en béton,
composé aux deux tiers de sable.
Conséquence : l'humanité
extrait 50 milliards
de tonnes de sable
et de granulat par an.
C'est la deuxième ressource
la plus exploitée sur la planète.
C'est un phénomène
qui s'accélère très vite.
A titre indicatif,
ces quatre dernières années,
la Chine
a consommé autant de sable
que les Etats-Unis en un siècle.
-Que sait-on de l'impact
sur l'environnement ?
-C'est pas clair,
mais l'ONU, en septembre,
a tiré la sonnette d'alarme
sur le sujet.
Première chose à savoir :
les ressources en sable
sont majoritairement
inexploitables sur la planète,
puisque ce sont d'abord les déserts
et que ce sable est impropre
à la construction, inutilisable.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce qu'il a été usé
par le vent,
donc il est plutôt lisse,
de petite taille.
Pour qu'un béton soit solide,
il faut qu'il y ait
des angles saillants,
pour que
ça s'agglomère correctement
et qu'on ait quelque chose
qui a du répondant, en termes
de contraintes physiques.
Personne
n'utilise ce sable
qui est pourtant là à profusion.
-A disposition.
-A titre d'exemple,
le gratte-ciel
le plus haut du monde, à Dubaï,
est en béton.
Savez-vous d'où vient le sable
qui a permis sa construction ?
D'Australie.
-En tout cas,
le sable ne vient pas du désert.
Les gerboises et les fennecs
sont épargnés.
Bonne nouvelle.
D'où vient le sable,
alors ?
-Celui qu'on utilise
vient des carrières, des plages,
du fond des lacs, du lit
des rivières,
des fonds marins.
Des endroits où, a priori,
il y a de la vie,
donc un impact
sur l'environnement
quand il y a une exploitation.
Ce sont
des systèmes de raclage
des fonds sableux qui embarquent
un petit peu tout.
Quand il y a des plantes,
des animaux,
tout ce que vous voulez,
c'est embarqué avec.
Au mieux, c'est déplacé.
Au pire,
c'est détruit.
Même la faune et la flore
qui ont été un peu épargnées
par la première vague
sont aussi impactées,
car il y a de la turbidité.
Ca veut dire
que ça resuspend
du sédiment,
donc la photosynthèse
ne se fait pas bien
et toute la chaîne
alimentaire locale
peut être impactée
par cette exploitation.
Les scientifiques
ont établi un lien
entre l'extraction du sable
et le déclin de la population
des dauphins du Gange.
C'est un exemple.
Il y a le recul des herbiers marins
en Indonésie,
ainsi que le recul
des tortues terrestres
en Malaisie.
Le grand boom
de l'Asie du Sud-Est
a eu beaucoup d'impact
sur l'environnement.
L'extraction du sable
a des conséquences topographiques.
Ca modifie les courants,
les profondeurs.
Tout ça
vient mettre le chaos
dans les habitats.
Ca a aussi
une incidence plus large.
Dans les embouchures
des fleuves exploités,
le sol descend et l'eau de mer
remonte,
donc le sel diffuse
dans les terres adjacentes
qui sont
empoisonnées.
Quand c'est des terres agricoles,
c'est un problème.
C'est le cas
dans l'embouchure du Mékong.
Le sol est descendu
et c'est une zone
de grande exploitation agricole.
-Vous connaissiez
ces chiffres ?
50 milliards de tonnes
de sable et de granulat
extraites tous les ans.
Votre entreprise,
comme d'autres,
recycle-t-elle le béton ?
-Déjà, la loi nous l'impose.
On a l'obligation
de récupérer nos déchets,
mais au regard du coût
de nos matières premières,
on a l'obligation de s'y intéresser.
Mon entreprise,
depuis 2007,
est certifiée NF HQE,
haute qualité environnementale.
On n'a pas attendu
les récentes actualités
pour s'y mettre.
Depuis 2007,
on se penche sur ce sujet.
Que peut-on faire de mieux
ou de différent ?
Que peut-on apporter ?
Parfois,
c'est modeste,
mais même le modeste est utile.
-Quel est le modeste ?
-Un exemple simple :
sur les laines qu'on met
dans les combles
pour isoler,
initialement des laines minérales,
eh bien, aujourd'hui,
on fait avec de la laine
de bois.
On a beaucoup d'isolants
qui sont issus
de la récupération industrielle,
que ce soient des tissus,
des PVC, etc.
C'est peu,
sur l'impact total
d'un bâtiment,
mais c'est un début.
-On parlait, tout à l'heure,
beaucoup du béton.
On utilise peu de bois
dans la construction en France.
Aux Etats-Unis,
c'est plutôt beaucoup le cas.
Quel est l'inconvénient qui fait
qu'on n'utilise pas plus ce bois ?
-Alors, le bois,
historiquement,
la filière française
l'a peu valorisé,
ou dans du très haut de gamme.
On n'avait pas
de grosse production,
comme ont eu les Allemands
sur des OSB, des choses comme ça.
Maintenant, on l'intègre.
Il y a beaucoup...
Dans une maison, c'est anecdotique,
mais quand on a un carrelage,
on fait historiquement
des plinthes en carrelage.
Nous, systématiquement,
on les fait en bois.
C'est peu, mais à l'échelle
de 300 000 logements,
c'est important.
-Et sur le bâti lui-même,
on peut envisager du bois,
quand même.
-Je fais de la construction bois,
en partie,
pour certaines de mes maisons.
On peut faire des planchers,
des escaliers en bois.
Tout ce qu'on ajoute
sera du mieux.
Ce sera pas 100 %,
pour l'instant,
mais on y va tout doucement.
-Vous êtes tous deux
architectes.
Par quoi remplacer le béton ?
-Je rebondis sur votre propos.
En Amérique du Nord
en général,
la construction bois
est très ancrée.
Une forte majorité des maisons
sont construites en bois.
Même les petits collectifs
sont en bois
dans les zones
où on pense à la densification.
Y compris aux Etats-Unis,
ça existe.
En Amérique du Sud, la terre
a été utilisée historiquement.
Elle a été remplacée
progressivement,
notamment pour
les grandes villes émergentes
des pays du Sud,
par les tours en béton,
mais les tours américaines
du début du siècle dernier
étaient en structure acier.
On a su faire autrement.
Il y a une question
d'imaginaire collectif, notamment
dans les pays émergents.
Les pays d'Asie,
d'Asie du Sud-Est,
considèrent que,
la tour en béton,
c'est un peu l'objet
qui montre la modernité
et l'accès à une certaine catégorie
de pays en développement,
ou développés, au contraire,
dans le monde moderne, mais je pense
qu'il y a aussi à travailler...
Ca paraît anecdotique,
mais cette question
de comment on perçoit
ce qui est vertueux
pour des raisons
d'attractivité économique
autant que d'engagement
écologique,
ça joue sur les filières
et leur capacité à trouver
un modèle économique viable
à un niveau de marché
suffisamment stable.
-Il y a une question aussi
de coût de main-d'oeuvre.
-Absolument.
On utilise le bois en charpente,
en menuiserie,
dans tout le second oeuvre,
mais quand on parle des maisons,
on doit être
à 10 % de parts de marché
si on est en ossature
et structure bois
et un petit peu en dessous
en petit collectif.
Il faut d'abord se dire
que oui...
Ca intéresse tout le monde,
le bois,
parce que
ça s'industrialise bien.
Ca plaît beaucoup
aux constructeurs
de "jouer aux Lego",
"je vais plus vite
que de bétonner et maçonner".
A un moment où il y a
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre,
ça intéresse.
Par contre, il y a
les questions de filière derrière
et de capacité.
On va pas multiplier par 10
ce qu'on sort
des forêts françaises.
On espérait avoir des forêts
assez en forme,
avec beaucoup de plantations
des années 50
qui donnent toute leur puissance
de capture du CO2.
Patatras,
le changement climatique,
les maladies, les sécheresses
font qu'on s'aperçoit
que nos forêts seront pas
si en forme que ça.
-Et qu'elles le sont pas.
-Elles sont d'ailleurs
moins puits de carbone
que ce qu'on espérait.
-La terre.
-Effectivement,
on peut aller chercher
tout un continuum.
-C'est un mix.
-Le bâtiment écolo, c'est pas
juste un truc en bois
avec des panneaux solaires
dessus,
c'est bien plus complexe.
On peut faire de la paille,
de la terre crue,
en briques, en pisé,
en adobe...
Il y a des proportions
importantes
de nos bâtiments,
même de cinq étages...
A Lyon, par exemple,
il y a beaucoup de bâtiments
qui sont construits en pisé.
-Qu'est-ce qui limite
l'utilisation de...
-C'est plus intensif
en main-d'oeuvre.
C'est des compétences.
Ensuite, il y a le coût,
parce qu'il faut
tasser la terre,
fabriquer les briques
à la main...
A la main, j'exagère,
mais c'est plus difficile
que les choses
qui sortent des industries.
Comme beaucoup
de sujets écolos...
C'est comme l'histoire
de la réparation.
Ca va vous coûter plus cher
de réparer votre aspirateur.
-Donc il faut des aides.
-Il faut, effectivement,
imaginer
qu'on passe, de manière progressive,
intelligente et pilotée
pour que les acteurs des filières
aient la visibilité,
puissent investir,
d'une fiscalité de la main-d'oeuvre,
la protection sociale,
les milliards d'euros
qui sont assis
sur le travail humain, très bien,
mais la fiscalité écolo, elle,
il y a rien.
Il va falloir basculer ça
pour être capable d'avoir
des choses plus intensives
en travail humain,
un travail humain
intéressant...
-Et de revenir aussi
à des savoir-faire
que l'on a perdus.
-C'est des emplois
de qualité,
pour la rénovation aussi,
pas que pour le neuf,
et être capable de faire ça
au détriment
de ce qui est intensif
en énergie.
-Transition toute trouvée
pour se demander comment
décarboner notre habitat.
Certains misent
sur les matériaux
moins polluants
et recyclables
comme le carton,
qui est un bon isolant.
Le monde de demain
commence aujourd'hui,
et croyez-moi,
il va cartonner,
comme le montre ce reportage
d'Emma Guizot et Ibar Aibar.
-La Vraie-Croix,
un petit village de Bretagne
comme les autres,
ou presque.
Au milieu des maisons en béton,
une se distingue,
celle de Nicolas Le Dirach,
qui a trouvé la solution...
-C'est par ici.
-...pour construire sa maison
avec zéro béton.
-La maison est posée
sur pieux.
On est
sur des pieux métalliques
vissés dans le sol.
Ca va être des pieux
qui sont enfoncés
à 4 mètres de profondeur.
C'est ce qui va soutenir l'ensemble
de la structure de la maison.
Là, on est sur un soutien
de 15 tonnes par pieu.
-Grâce à ces pieux,
la bâtisse de Nicolas
est surélevée
et empêche
l'artificialisation du sol.
L'eau ruisselle normalement,
la biodiversité est préservée.
-Si, dans 100 ans,
on décide
de démonter la maison,
on peut retirer les pieux,
réétaler la terre,
et le terrain est
comme on l'avait trouvé
à l'achat.
-Nicolas a construit lui-même
sa maison de 138 m carrés.
A 39 ans,
il vient d'ouvrir
sa propre société
de construction.
Autrefois installateur
de maisons en bois,
aujourd'hui, il utilise
un autre matériau
pas comme les autres.
-Alors, vous voyez ?
Si on coupe la membrane qui fait
l'étanchéité à l'eau...
Hop... Voilà.
On retrouve le carton
juste derrière.
C'est un carton recyclé,
c'est un carton
comme on trouve partout,
les cartons d'emballage
et ainsi de suite.
On est vraiment zéro béton.
-La maison de Nicolas
est la troisième de ce type
en France.
Il s'est fourni
en matériaux
chez Bat'Ipac,
l'entreprise novatrice
des maisons en carton.
Son président, Alain Marboeuf,
vient contrôler l'assemblage
des structures murales
en bois et carton
dans leur atelier
de Saint-Nazaire.
-Salut, Cédric.
Tu vas bien ?
Bon, ça y est ?
T'es en préparation
d'un nouveau mur ?
On fait une ossature primaire,
et on vient mettre
les blocs derrière le placoplâtre
et le bardage.
C'est bien du carton
qui est à l'intérieur.
C'est grâce aux alvéoles
qu'il y a là,
qui contiennent de l'air.
C'est un bon isolant thermique,
phonique et acoustique.
-Pour une maison
de 170 m carrés,
il faudra 15 jours d'assemblage
en atelier,
puis trois jours de chantier
pour que la maison en carton
soit prête à accueillir
ses habitants.
-Le bloc central
qui constitue le mur principal,
que l'on voit ici.
Derrière cela, on a le pare-pluie
qui protège le bloc,
le bardage
avec sa lame d'air,
et puis, à l'intérieur,
le bloc de cinq
qui sert de pare-vapeur
à l'intérieur de la maison,
les rails de placo,
avec ici du placo,
même si c'est un bout de bois,
qui permet de passer
l'électricité, l'eau,
tout ce qu'il peut y avoir
dans une maison.
-Ces maisons en carton
ne risquent-elles pas
de s'envoler ?
-Ce produit-là
a des propriétés mécaniques.
L'eau ne traverse pas,
mais il est mécaniquement
aussi résistant.
Actuellement, ils sont en train
de construire à Brest
un ensemble
de six maisons en bande,
et ces ensembles de bâtiments
ont subi les deux tempêtes
que nous avons eues.
Les bâtiments sont debout,
il se passe rien.
-Comme le béton,
le carton est solide et étanche,
mais il est en plus
respectueux de l'environnement.
-Aujourd'hui, le carton
issu du recyclage
est recyclable
neuf fois sur lui-même
sans apport de matière neuve.
Donc quand je prends
ce petit bloc de carton
et que je le recycle,
je peux le faire neuf fois
sans aller chercher
un arbre, ni d'ailleurs
d'autres matières.
Une maison tient 80 ans.
Si on la recycle tous les 80 ans,
on est sur un millénaire
sans avoir été prendre
de la ressource.
C'est du développement durable
soutenable.
-Bat'Ipac compte déjà
une centaine de réalisations
en France.
A environ 2000 euros
le mètre carré,
les prix sont proches de ceux
d'un pavillon traditionnel,
mais les économies se font
surtout dans la durée.
Retour dans le Morbihan,
dans la maison de Nicolas.
Son isolation en carton
lui permet de dépenser
moins de 100 euros de chauffage
chaque année.
-En ce moment,
on est sur une température
de 20 degrés dans la maison.
Ca fait 15 jours que le poêle
ne s'est pas mis en route.
Le poêle s'est mis en route une fois
pendant une heure,
juste pour rehausser la température
parce qu'on était descendu
en dessous de 18,
tout simplement
parce qu'on n'avait pas eu
de soleil
pendant au moins
une semaine et demie.
-La maison est douillette,
charmante,
et Nicolas est intarissable
sur ses qualités.
-Grâce au carton ici,
on a aussi
une propriété acoustique
qui est très intéressante,
parce qu'on fait une réduction
de 44 décibels
des bruits aériens,
chose que...
Par exemple,
sur une maison traditionnelle,
on est plutôt
sur 25 décibels.
Donc on est sur une performance
acoustique
qui fait qu'on se retrouve
vraiment dans un cocon
une fois qu'on est
dans la maison.
-Six maisons
comme celle de Nicolas
verront le jour à Brest
en avril 2024.
-Un matériau recyclable
jusqu'à sept fois,
qui ne se consume pas
plus vite
qu'un autre,
voici une architecture
frugale et durable.
Ca vous inspire,
Sylvain ?
-Bien sûr.
Toutes les expériences
sont bonnes à prendre.
Il faut laisser sa chance
à chacune, regarder
les niveaux de maturation
et de capacité à massifier,
ce qui va être
le plus dur. 100 maisons,
c'est un bon début.
Les 500 000 logements,
il va falloir les faire.
-Avant,
pour être un grand maire,
il fallait avoir
une grande ville.
Dans le sud,
en raison de la sécheresse,
certains maires
refusent de délivrer
des permis de construire.
Ils ont raison ?
-Je le vois dans beaucoup
de régions aujourd'hui.
C'est effectivement
l'effet des deux derniers étés
avec des sécheresses très marquées,
y compris dans le nord-est.
Les élus ont réalisé
que leur rêve de développement
était limité
par l'accès à l'eau,
qui est bien souvent
assez complexe pour eux.
Dans le sud-est,
c'est déjà très occupé,
donc c'est déjà
le conflit de l'eau,
mais dans des régions agricoles,
il y a d'autres formes
de conflit de l'eau,
on le voit dans l'ouest.
On a beaucoup de difficulté
à accepter de nouveaux habitants
et de nouveaux usages.
Donc ça commence à être
un révélateur,
un choc de constatation
de ces différentes pénuries.
Je pense qu'on n'en est pas là
pour le sable,
mais on finira aussi
par rencontrer cette pénurie
de matière première.
On a fait un exercice
avec plusieurs villes
moyennes,
qui ont perdu de la population
ces dernières années,
notamment dans l'agglomération
d'Epernay, pour savoir
si le développement urbain
tel qu'il a été réalisé
et promu sur un village
de 5000 habitants...
Le maire nous explique
qu'il a fait
4 lotissements en 20 ans
et qu'il a perdu 1000 habitants.
Donc il y a aussi à déconstruire
l'idée reçue que
faire plus de logements,
ça ferait venir plus de gens.
Pour autant, on comprend bien
les aspirations à augmenter
de deux ou trois familles
la population du village
pour ne pas fermer une classe
dans une école, etc.
C'est très objectif,
la manière dont les élus
décident de construire.
Il faut plutôt produire
que construire du logement.
C'est là qu'on revient à l'idée
qu'il y a déjà un stock
et que le "déjà là"
est susceptible
d'accueillir aussi
les besoins du territoire.
-Au nom de la défense
de la ruralité,
les élus dont Laurent Wauquiez,
président
de la région Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes,
refusent d'appliquer
cette politique
de sobriété foncière.
Qu'auriez-vous envie de lui dire,
l'un et l'autre ?
-Philippe.
-J'espère que j'aurai...
-Je suis sûre
qu'il nous écoute.
-... la joie de le rencontrer
pour lui en parler.
Ce zéro artificialisation nette,
il rencontre un écho
qui est assez positif.
C'est pas juste négatif.
Il y a une vraie prise de conscience
de cette question.
C'est pas juste
pour la biodiversité.
C'est aussi pour notre résilience
alimentaire. Pendant 50 ans,
les rendements agricoles
augmentaient,
donc c'était pas grave,
on transformait
les friches.
Il faut sortir de ça.
Il y a une compréhension
de ça aujourd'hui.
Les villes ne peuvent pas
avoir vocation à croître
et à se développer
éternellement.
Au rythme
où on artificialise,
dans cinq à six siècles,
on parlait de 1000 ans
dans le reportage,
on va s'arrêter à la moitié,
l'ensemble des terres agricoles
seront couvertes
de ronds-points,
de parkings.
Ca peut pas fonctionner
comme ça.
Il faut aller chercher une logique
où les maires bâtisseurs,
et en 2020,
il y en a déjà quelques-uns
qui se sont fait sortir
dans quelques endroits,
il y a cette logique de dire
que les maires doivent
embellir, réparer, transformer,
adapter les villes
aux enjeux climatiques.
-Vous entendez ça,
Sylvain Massonneau ?
Qu'auriez-vous envie de dire
à un client potentiel
qui a envie
de sa maison individuelle
et qui en rêve ?
-Et à M. Wauquiez,
mon président de région.
-Qu'avez-vous envie de lui dire ?
-M. Wauquiez,
il a eu cette formule choc
pour imposer à la classe politique
de se réintéresser au sujet.
-Il faut reconnaître
qu'il a donné une publicité
invraisemblable à ce texte.
-Je pense que la genèse
a été un peu rapide
et dogmatique.
Le coup d'éclat de M. Wauquiez
a surtout vocation
à remettre les pieds
sur terre.
Il a envie de montrer
qu'il y a un vrai sujet.
Dans ce vrai sujet,
quand on rentre
dans la technique
opérationnelle du ZAN,
il y a quand même
quelques sujets de vexation.
Je vais prendre
un exemple simple.
Quand on prend un terrain
à construire,
1000 m carrés,
c'est beaucoup plus
que ce que peuvent
se payer les gens,
aujourd'hui, on est plutôt
sur 350 m carrés,
sur 1000 m carrés, on met
une maison de 100 m carrés,
on a artificialisé
les 1000 m carrés.
Les gens ne comprennent pas
qu'on dise
que leur terrain
est artificialisé.
Ils ne comprennent pas
que la biodiversité
qu'ils apportent dans un jardin
de maison soit pire
que le champ de céréales
en monoculture.
Aujourd'hui, M. Wauquiez
se fait le porte-parole
de cette vexation.
-J'aimerais qu'on jette
un coup d'oeil dans le rétro.
Comme chaque mois,
Charlotte Epale
est allée fouiller
dans les archives de l'INA
et nous a exhumé ceci.
Hier encore,
c'est notre coup d'oeil
dans le rétro,
et c'est maintenant.
-Je vous propose
de suivre Jérôme Bony
dans les gorges de la Loire,
le long de ce magnifique
massif du Pilat,
pour suivre son reportage
consacré à un lotissement
qui pourrait bien défigurer
cet endroit merveilleux.
-Oui, Noël,
et vous allez voir
qu'en fait,
le pire est déjà fait.
Je vous laisse d'abord admirer
ces gorges de la Loire,
lieu de promenade privilégié
des Stéphanois.
C'est ce site
que l'ancienne municipalité
de Saint-Etienne a choisi
pour établir une zone
d'aménagement concerté
à 15 km de la ville,
et ce juste avant 75,
c'est-à-dire
sans étude d'impact.
Les promoteurs sont arrivés,
et c'est comme par hasard
le site le plus visible
qui a été construit
en premier.
Et la Commission des sites ?
Elle ne s'était pas réunie
pendant 3 ans.
Peut-être l'hiver sera-t-il rude
pour ces accédants à la propriété
sur ce plateau exposé au vent.
Il est écrit
dans le permis de construire
qu'il faudra prévoir
des tas de sable
pour le verglas. Il est évident
que ce hameau est bien isolé.
C'est votre résidence principale.
Où pensez-vous faire vos courses ?
-Avec la voiture et le supermarché.
Le village n'est pas loin,
on peut faire les courses
en voiture.
-Cette opération avait été lancée
par l'ancienne municipalité
de Saint-Etienne,
mais la nouvelle devait-elle
vraiment la concrétiser ?
-Il était aberrant de vouloir
urbaniser ces plateaux
au-dessus des gorges
de la Loire.
-Et les dommages sur le plan
du site lui-même ?
Vous avez laissé construire
sur l'endroit le plus visible
quand on admire les gorges.
-"L'endroit le plus visible",
je ne vous suivrai pas
totalement sur ce point.
C'est l'ensemble des abords
du hameaux de Condamine
qui est visible
de l'autre côté des gorges
de la Loire.
-C'est particulièrement
dommageable.
-Ah, mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous.
En matière d'urbanisme,
il y a des coûts partis
que l'on peut regretter
mais qui sont malheureusement,
comme on le dit dans ce jargon,
des coûts partis.
-La ville de Saint-Etienne avait
investi 10 millions de francs
pour l'adduction d'eau
et d'électricité.
La nouvelle municipalité,
en bradant ce terrain viabilisé
pour 30 francs le mètre carré,
aura contribué à offrir
à des revenus moyens
une vue exceptionnelle.
-30 francs le mètre carré,
voilà un bel exemple
d'étalement urbain.
Impossible de nous quitter
sans donner la parole
à Camille Etienne.
Elle a quelque chose
à vous dire, c'est l'heure
de sa Carte verte.
Camille, à vous.
-On perd la taille
d'un département
sous le béton tous les 10 ans.
Alors que les sécheresses menacent
nos cultures,
on condamne les terres agricoles
pour des entrepôts,
on laisse les bulldozers s'accaparer
les vergers,
nos forêts être incisées
pour une piste de ski de plus.
Mais les autres,
ceux qu'on oublie
jusqu'à ce qu'on voie des dauphins
dans les canaux des villes
et des biches traverser
les passages piétons
quand nous étions confinés
entre nos murs qui maintenaient
nos existences.
A eux, nos voisins de prairie,
que leur reste-t-il ?
Que leur laisse-t-on ?
Où vont donc
les oiseaux sans arbre,
les cerfs sans forêt ?
Ils disparaissent ?
L'artificialisation des sols
est la première cause
de la 6e extinction de masse.
De leur dehors,
on en fait notre intérieur.
On les congédie ailleurs
sans qu'il n'y ait d'ailleurs.
La vie se vide
parce qu'on avale son socle.
On construit une terre sans terre,
quand la menace est dans le titre.
Il y a quelques années,
certains avaient sonné l'alarme.
Ils étaient 150, la fameuse
Convention citoyenne sur le climat.
On leur avait demandé de trouver
comment stopper notre course
avant l'abîme.
Une des premières mesures,
l'article 52 de la loi,
qui imposait un moratoire
sur toute structure soumise
à autorisation commerciale
de plus de 10 000 mètres carrés
artificialisant des sols.
Ca veut dire pause,
on arrête de couler le monde
sous le béton,
sans réfléchir.
Nos décideurs ont rajouté
une petite astérisque, l'exception.
On arrête
sauf pour les entreprises privées.
Les entrepôts d'e-commerce ont
le droit, eux.
On arrête de construire
sauf pour vous, M. Amazon,
qui faites disparaître
plus d'emplois que vous n'en créez,
qui condamnez
des terres cultivables
pour y empiler des flingues
en plastiques ou des ordinateurs,
parce que c'est important
pour tous les Français
de pouvoir recevoir chez eux
des baskets qui clignotent.
Plus important que nos champs.
L'opposition contre ces entrepôts
s'organisent autour de vous.
Des gens se soulèvent pour refuser
ce monde de béton
de Lafarge ou d'Amazon,
contre un entrepôt
de 42 000 mètres carrés à Louailles,
contre un autre entrepôt
de 160 mètres carrés.
En Alsace, à Belfort, à Lyon,
à Quimper, à Rouen,
rejoignez-les,
ils n'attendent que vous.
Restons attentifs autour de nous,
où réside encore un peu
de beauté du monde,
sans qu'on aille la chercher
ailleurs.
Restons prêts pour refuser
leur appétit insatiable
d'artificialiser
ce qui se passerait d'artifice.
Face à ce qu'il reste de terre,
comme disait Corinne Morel Darleux,
cheminez sur cette ligne de crête
qui oscille entre inquiétude
et émerveillement.
Trouver nos équilibres implique
une aptitude à déceler la beauté,
à s'en réjouir et à poser
un regard lucide et déterminé
sur ce qui est en train
de la saccager.
J'ajouterais en bref, se battre
pour elle et en son nom.
-Une réaction ?
-Oui pour dire
que ce que nous avons évoqué,
c'est l'envie de faire plus sobre,
de respecter ce qui est déjà là.
S'il y a quelque chose à retenir,
ce qu'il faut regarder
ce qu'on a sous les pieds
avant de penser
à ce dont on n'a pas besoin.
-Valoriser l'existant,
pour résumer.
-J'ai envie de rebondir
sur la beauté du monde.
Avec le reportage de l'INA aussi,
sur la zone pavillonnaire moche
alors qu'il y a le plus beau village
de France pas loin.
Comment a-t-on construit
pendant des siècles
de manière aussi belle
et patrimoniale ?
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, on doit pas
construire moins mais mieux,
plus durable, sans être frappé
d'obsolescence. Les lieux sont aussi
frappés d'obsolescence.
C'est ce rapport
qu'il faut réinventer,
avec une chance incroyable,
ce patrimoine existant
qui est un terrain de jeu
pour toutes les professions.
-Sylvain Massonneau ?
-Je retiens des reportages
l'usage et les fonctions
d'un lieu de vie.
La maison est en train
de devenir un lieu de travail,
d'éducation avec les tutoriels.
C'est un lieu d'apprentissage
de l'écologie.
Ca été bien dit sur la faune
et la flore immédiates,
quand on vit dans un jardin,
on accède à tout ça.
Mes enfants distinguent
les oiseaux.
Ils ont vu leurs tomates sécher
lors des canicules
de 2020, 2021, 2022, 2023.
Ils se disent
qu'il y a un problème.
Ca sert aussi à ça,
un jardin et une maison.
C'est cette proximité
qu'il faut promouvoir
et ne pas balayer
en disant qu'elle est moche.
-Merci à tous les quatre.
Avant de nous quitter,
des recommandations
pour aller plus loin.
"La ville stationnaire",
de Philippe Bihouix.
C'est un indispensable.
Pour Sylvain Massonneau,
"Le tour des matériaux
d'une maison écologique",
la bible de la construction sobre.
"Formes urbaines
"et biodiversité,
un état des connaissances"
de Morgane Flegeau.
Et "Objectif ZAN,
"apprendre du périurbain
et des campagnes urbaines",
de Sylvain Allemand.
C'est en ligne.
Bonne lecture.
On se retrouve en 2024.
D'ici là, soyez heureux.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...